[Musica]
al aqsa dove mi trovo adesso
sei ettari e lombardia chissà quante
volte
avrete fatto queste domande all'ex negli
ultimi anni
al giorno d'oggi dispositivi aiuti si
trovano quasi ovunque ma cosa sono i
dispositivi aiuti
ogni oggetto al giorno d'oggi può essere
collegato ad internet
dal dai baby monitor alle camere di
sicurezza persino il nostro frigorifero
può essere collegato internet questi
oggetti che hanno la capacità di essere
collegati a internet si chiamano
internet delle cose internet of things e
sono meravigliosi perché fare ci rendono
una vita comoda e facile
riproducono la nostra musica
fanno in modo di aiutare i nostri figli
a fare i compiti
ma cosa in realtà nascondono
soprattutto stiamo svendendo la nostra
privacy per dei servizi minori
quando sono arrivata a londra da madrid
dove stavo sfogliando il dottorato stavo
studiando internet
come migliorarlo e velocizzarlo dovevo
decidere se continuare su questa su
questo percorso di ricerca
o
cambiare tema
e allora una sarà mio padre mi telefona
dall'italia andando spira puoi vivere
intelligente che ci hai regalato è
impazzita
riesco vedere dal mio cellulare le mappe
delle case di altre persone e anche i
loro nomi e allora dico
perché ha un aspirapolvere
il cui compito è quello semplicemente di
raccogliere la polvere dal pavimento ha
bisogno di collegarsi così tanto
internet e trasmettere così tanto
traffico quindi quello che faccio è
e cattura tutto il traffico che
l'aspirapolvere stavamo andando
su internet in italia nella casella dove
attualmente risiede la mia famiglia e
vedo che questa sfida polvere stava
inviando talmente tanto traffico
comunque è una cosa sospettosa e allora
avevo deciso cosa volevo fare per la mia
prossima ricerca volevo capire quale
modello di business
questi dispositivi utilizzano sulla
nostra privacy sui nostri dati e allora
non parlo con il mio collega a metadati
professore l'imperial college di londra
e iniziamo a comprare centinaia di
dispositivi aiuti tutti quelli che
potevamo trovare online nel mercato
inglese quindi da
cat
macchine per fare il caffè
abbiamo persino una macchina per
cucinare il riso perché è troppo scomodo
premere il pulsante per cucinare il riso
sia bisogno di cucinarlo dal divano ma
questa è un'altra storia
ma non ci è bastato perché abbiamo
pensato
che vogliamo sapere da te le leggi ei
regolamenti che ci sono in europa
rispetto alla privacy per il trattamento
dei nostri dati come differentemente
questi dispositivi si comportavano in
base al passato in cui erano stati
acquistati con cui erano comunque
situati e allora abbiamo
unito le nostre forze con la
northeastern university a boston che già
aveva costruito un ministro di apartment
piano di dispositivi aiuti
gemelli dei dispositivi che avevamo
acquistato in inghilterra abbiamo
iniziato a catturare tutto il traffico
che questi dispositivi inviavano
attraverso internet
per un totale di 200 dispositivi
l'abbiamo fatto per due anni e mezzo e
ancora stiamo continuando a catturare il
traffico abbiamo anche fatto dei
implementate delle strategie per
automatizzare l'utilizzo di questi
dispositivi in modo tale che
apparisse come se fossero usati da
utenti normali
e quello che abbiamo scoperto è stato
abbastanza interessante anche e anche
sorprendente all'inizio perché abbiamo
visto che la maggior parte del traffico
che erano collegati in gran bretagna non
andava a finire in europa ma finiva in
altri stati dove le leggi della privacy
non esistono come stati uniti dove
l'unica legge della privacy esiste in
california e soprattutto cina dove la
maggior parte di questi dispositivi sono
comunque prodotti e allora il vero
rischio qui non è tanto che informazioni
vengono mandate da questi dispositivi
ma dove sono mandati perché sono
inviati i nostri dati al di fuori del
nostro della nostra giurisdizione
di regolamento della privacy
abbiamo scoperto anche altri
comportamenti diciamo inaspettati per
esempio
del dei citofoni intelligenti molto
popolari inviavano il movimento di ogni
utente che passava in fronte al al derby
di fuoco in fronte al citofono
al cloud nella nube diciamo attraverso
internet anche se noi comunque
attraverso l'app non aveva avevamo non
avevamo optato per questo tipo di
funzionalità e anche le varie
televisioni di marche anche importanti
si collegavano a netflix google e
facebook senza che noi avessimo mai
installato l'app e senza che
avessimo neanche creato un account
in questo tipo di compagnia è il
risultato più sorprendente è venuto
fuori da uno studio che abbiamo fatto
sul gli altoparlanti intelligenti lisma
speakers come alexa google
siri un po abbiamo scoperto che questi
dispositivi si attivavano anche senza
dover dire la parola chiave a volte per
più di dieci volte al giorno questo è un
enorme rischio per la privacy perché
siamo si tratta di un dispositivo che a
un microfono attivato 24 ore su 24 a
casa nostra è che alla capacità di
attivarsi anche quando non diciamo la
parola chiave perché comunque capisce
intende male un'altra parola o perché
sente una parola simile della
televisione e quindi può registrare fino
a 20 secondi e mandare la registrazione
direttamente su internet e questo è un
gravissimo problema per la privacy
da un altro studio è emerso che
questi dispositivi contatto delle
destinazioni che sono esclusive per
l'utilizzo dei dispositivi
che significa significa che guardando
semplicemente il traffico internet
siamo stati in grado di riconoscere il
tipo di dispositivo che l'utente ha in
casa ma anche che uso l'utente fa del
dispositivo quindi io guardando
semplicemente quello di service provider
comunque mi fornisce internet guardando
semplicemente il traffico di rate
dell'utente può sapere se io sono in
casa non sono in casa perché posso fare
il momento esatto in cui ho spento ho
acceso la lampadina intelligente o
accesso aperto o chiuso comunque la
porta
ho acceso usato da camera di sicurezza
per controllare se qualcuno fosse in
casa
quindi abbiamo scoperto che è il 57 per
cento delle destinazioni dagli stati
uniti e il 50 per cento delle sti
nazioni della gran bretagna non sono
destinazioni che appartengono al
produttore ma sono quelle che noi
definiamo terze parti o anche parti di
supporto e queste terze parti
cioè è lecito che i dispositivi
contattino queste terze parti
addirittura l'utente lo sa lo sa cioè
noi lo sappiamo siamo stati informati e
siamo stati informati nel momento in cui
abbiamo installato il dispositivo e ci
sono state fornite quelle 40 pagine di
trans e condition termini e condizioni
che ovviamente nessuno di noi l'ha già
perché uno sono troppo vaghe secondo
sono troppo lunghe e terzo se non
vengono accettate non si può usare il
dispositivo
molta gente mi chiede ok
in inglese si dice ai don card non me ne
frega niente se un'azienda in california
ai miei dati cosa può succedere
il discorso non è tanto il fatto che un
dipendente amazon in california può
vedere cosa hai fatto cosa non è fatto
tu in casa
il discorso è molto più complicato
perché avviene quello che noi definiamo
scientificamente profilazione cioè
conoscendo il più possibile di un utente
quindi bombardato da questi sensori
l'utilizzo anche del cellulare di social
si crea un profilo unico
dell'utente è questi profili sono usati
per creare quella che viene chiamata
un'influenza di massa si pensi per
esempio allo scandalo di cambridge
analitica si può addirittura arrivare ad
influenzare il voto di un individuo e
questa è una cosa gravissima anche per
esempio
il suono della nostra voce
questo è un ricco
è ricco di informazioni sono della
nostra voce quindi quando noi
utilizziamo per esempio con qualsiasi
altoparlante intelligente in realtà le
aziende che lo producono possono sapere
il nostro livello di stress possono
capire il nostro genere possono sapere
la nostra età e questo può naturalmente
a lungo termine portare a delle
decisioni che potrebbero sembrare nostre
ma che le altre ci sono state fornite
come soluzione all'algoritmo che questi
che queste compagnie stanno utilizzando
analizzando la nostra voce
e allora io mi chiedo
sappiamo bene che al aqsa con e adesso
come oggi non sarà in vent'anni ci sarà
qualcos'altro qualcos'altro che
sicuramente sarà molto più sofisticato e
quindi cosa succederà quando queste
macchine diventeranno delle vere e
proprie protesi cognitive e quindi ci
aiuteranno nelle nostre scelte
ma non solo ci aiuteranno sta però non
prima di noi
cosa vogliamo
dove finisce la volontà di un individuo
addirittura i dati che sono stati che
sono raccolti che vengono raccolti da
questi dispositivi
oggi possono influenzare il futuro dei
nostri nipoti perché per esempio al
nostro nipote gli si può negare una
assicurazione sanitaria basata sulla
storia della famiglia dei dati raccolti
negli ultimi 40 anni
per fortuna comunque noi ad imperial
vediamo un futuro migliore in gioco dove
ci sarà una trasparenza della privacy e
quindi stiamo lavorando a un dispositivo
che abbiamo chiamato ios rim che aiuterà
a filtrare quella che adesso nei nostri
dati prima che arrivano prima che
arrivino al cloud alla nube direttamente
a casa dell'utente nel proprio router
abbiamo già analizzato 31 dispositivi
nel nostro laboratorio e abbiamo visto
che è possibile bloccare 60 per cento
delle destinazioni che questi
dispositivi contattano e tutti i
dispositivi continuano comunque a
funzionare questo significa che io posso
ottenere il traffico posso inviare il
traffico che il dispositivo utilizza per
funzionare quindi per raccogliere la
polvere in casinò spira polvere per fare
lo streaming di un video incastra una
telecamera di sicurezza e bloccare tutto
il resto delle comunicazioni ci sarà
abbiamo stiamo studiando l'interfaccia
grafica in modo tale che l'utente
possa
scegliere decidere quale destinazione
tenare o comunque vedere i dati che sono
mandati i provinati che siamo andati
attraverso internet e decidere quale
filtrare e quale no ma finalmente
l'utente il potere tornerà nelle mani
dell'utente
e allora chiediamo
al aqsa stai rubando per caso i miei
dati
purtroppo non trovo le risposte alla
domanda
grazie